yo tout le monde sait squeeze écoutez je
suis encore beaucoup affecté par les
commentaires que vous avez laissé sur ma
vidéo poker rang ou parce que c'est
plein de gentillesse d'amour de bonté et
d'admiration jeu l'approuvent il est
vrai je dessine mal voilà au lieu d'une
bonne fois pour toutes mais par contre
je me suis dit est ce que mes abonnés
eux dessine bien hein parce qu'il se
permet de critiquer mes véritables
oeuvres d'art mais aussi font des
oeuvres d'art c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur drouot
something 2 c'est le seul moyen de
savoir si vous dessinez bien on va
commencer avec anadrome c'est parti à la
drogue oui qu'est-ce que c'est une
machine à laver à taureaux trop facile
un rond dans un carré machine à laver
bravo à la drôme c'était parfait tu peux
vendre tes tableaux au louvre trois
pièces abbas doit pas être très sains
oula oula est franchement là ça sent les
guirlandes quand même au début j'ai cru
que c'était des personnages avec des
manteaux différentes couleurs de dos sur
une colline mais non une guirlande voilà
ce qui n'a rien à voir ouais bravo pour
ce qu'aucun un qui fait un truc lui la
tenue qui n'attend que ça cette pièce où
c'est un peu plus dur en tout cas il a
effacé c'était trop mauvais bybee aux
babys aux étoiles r étoiles bieber oh
non pas chaffai pas deviner bieber baby
1 attend maintenant un bel écart ou mal
fait quoi justin bieber fallait faire
des cheveux en vrac ou pop up à une
mèche de surfer et ce qu'il a une
carrure de rugbyman justin bieber je ne
crois pas bon il était pas les yeux
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça 2
cerceau rouge un ange tu faisais juste
un mec avec un cerceau au dessus de la
tête hop anges c'est parti cette pièce
où dame
am je ne sais pas ce que ckac et c'est
la poule par contre là c'est pour l'auto
grave ça me fait très plaisir ça je vais
les attends je screen parce que hope la
voile à encadrer chez moi emilie
gribouille
on va voir si emilie gribouille as tu
une femme blonde et tulle entouré en
hublots c'est peut-être le match nadal
avait tout à l'heure qui représentait
parleront et une fille qui est dans la
machine à laver qui sourit en regardant
à travers le hublot à visage c'est pour
ça que temps au tour et ses cheveux plus
soumises à m et me dit c'est quoi ça
c'est du gribouillis c'est pas du dessin
valeur 13 pièces alors c'est quoi mon
gars mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça à
terme on peut croire que c'est qu'à mon
plein de choses quoi une fleur un corner
à trois boules une fusée une [ __ ]
abandonner c'était quoi alors j'ai pas
la réponse sera jamais ce que c'était
les inhiber temps ça peut nous y aider
numéro un numéro de un homme qui trompe
sa copine amant narnia pas il ya
beaucoup d'amour dans cette image mais
j'ai sûr pas la solution à j'ai trouvé
en fait ses débuts d'un film d'horreur
il ya deux fictions amoureuse d'un mec
et le coupe en deux pour chacun un petit
peu de lui voilà c'est glauque au revoir
bombe à écouter chez sa source est
carrément évident pour vous de votre
écran mais pour moi ça ne l'est pas du
tout un fidèle c'est horrible parce
qu'après coup ça te paraît tellement
évident alors que sur le coup tu es
tellement comme une merde bon un
bonhomme de neige
un homme torse nu c'est quoi ça donc si
je comprends bien c'est un mec qui a un
début de calvitie qu'il a absolument
aucun style vous qui met un pantalon
vert avec des bottes bleues il a deux
petites et tourner des oreilles
décollées comme pas permis d énormes
boucles d'oreilles et ckoi dans sa main
c'est quoi ces flaques de sang c'est
niet qui explique bien la flaque de sang
dans sa main je suis nul je sais pas moi
l'action était tellement mis sur cette
grande paire d'oreilles que j'étais
bloqué là dessus attends c'est un
vêtement avec une tache jaune c'est
jaune s'allie au j'y croyais tellement
c'est sale et à ses seuls à oui c'est ça
les quoi le tee shirts allez va merci
louis c'était très bien pareil tu peux
exposer ses tableaux louvre sans
problème
ils accepteront la colline a des yeux
puisque c'est à elle abandonné là qu'un
roots et tunnels il a tellement bien
fait c'est incroyable et c'est grâce aux
petites lumières jaunes sur les sur le
côté qui font tout elles ont tout fait
dans ce dessein teint c'était vraiment
de l'art là pour le coup alors à allah
je crois que c'est un autre niveau par
contre une souris sont déjà sur des
échasses
les libellules nickel cinéma cinéma
cinéma il sait très bien tous des saints
pourquoi tu as commencé le mec qui fait
un dessin super bien qu'ils expliquent
carrément tout il mais l'écran les
spectateurs et tous puis les faces et
pays d'essayer une tortue tarder ce
n'est pas mal du tout je suis vexé bas
ça augmente encore plus beaux complexes
j'adore l'explication les points comme
la peine de faire une sorte de soleil se
battre ou c'est un soleil ou c'est un
morceau de baskets jaunes en tout cas
ses nageoires bien jouer thomas p
l'homme torse nu tout m'appelle c'est un
réseau pour séduire des filles bien
c'est juste pour dessiner tu peux
remettre un tee shirt attendant attend
le mef devaient dessiner pikachu il a
fait ce truc
en quoi ces pikachu tard tu pouvais
faire carrément mieux c'est pas du tout
pikachu non moi j'aurais dit c'est
plutôt mu nairas même s'il n'existe pas
ce pokémon d'année puisqu'elle a pas les
lettres qu'il faut poser un pikachu donc
c'est quoi non je crois qu'ils veulent
juste trop les par rapport à pau kedro
le mot était vasque il m'a effectivement
un troll et par rapport aux progrès
d'euros fromage bien sûr à 18 pièces
par contre le coût des mentalités à
facilités ça y est on fait enfin un
triangle bd tout up et mentale bon il
est vrai que vous avez votre petit bout
en dessin voilà je peux pas lutter je
peux pas lutter contre ça et jolis
dessins et une perspective et tout s'est
vraiment très recherchés de la part de
l'artiste
bon je reconnais le terrain de basket le
ballon de basket qui se dirige vers le
panier de basket tous tes baskets mêmes
mots c'est pas parce qu'elle a abandonné
le mot était il m'a pas dit abbas avaya
patronne indice est pauvre qu'est ce que
c'est que ce truc un mouton un éléphant
un éléphant qui boit dans une mare un
éléphant gris ya pas être aux avant de
mettre la dernière lettre j'aimerais
juste qu'on admire un petit peu ce
téléphone cet homme ni vu ni connu se
feront plus grand que la beauce un
dromadaire cette queue qui est en fait
un poil c'est ça le dessin alors la
planète terre comme c'est bien fait
meteor pommette et bakou tu sais
parfaitement décidé une terre stéphane
on aurait dit une sorte de mini lac avec
un peu des algues obs les terres nickel
un tableau cinéma cordialement
est ce que je veux faire frôler le mec
dessine un carré me dit cordialement
date roll le mot était rectangle il
était parfait ce rectangle en plus il
était parfait c'était tout ce qu'on
attend d'un rectangle voilà quatre côtés
comme sa baguette
donc il a mis un truc au milieu avec
3,13 peut-être une baguette quand
soudain dick pas et au dessus qu'est ce
que c'est que ça c'est un morceau de
pain en lévitation c'est ça y est c'est
et y est c'est pendant ce temps
lévitation s'éteignait l'uqam et la
miette et n'est pas comme ça elle est
comme ça la miette de pain attend est en
miettes de pain est carrément énorme
quoi c'est le quignon carrément s'est
mis à saigner
heureusement que tu à l'heure je suis
tombé sur un truc comme ça que j'avais
compris banon coupe et coupe ou y coupe
est touché le mot était touché mais
quand tu touches tu saignes toi mais non
mais non mais c'est vrai quoi le match
ici saigne la mort est-ce que dès que tu
touches tu saignes au nom gmao luca luca
c'est bon tu t'appelles l'uqat et
pardonner mais ans lucas alors qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire parce que
cette femme pleure du sang courir j'ai
voulu écrire courir je n'ai pas trouvé
le une imbécile c'est indiana jones
le big mac l'indication puis les faces
pour faire comme si de rien n'était ah
bah voilà ça faisait longtemps que j'ai
pas trouvé c'est sa spectaculaire
c'est la remontée c'est la remontée ou
là c'est un biceps annonce quelqu'un qui
allonge et ça c'est l'indication
pourquoi il ya des traits comme ça c'est
un chat qui est sûr c'est que ça c'est
quoi
afrique attends attends attends la malle
et il fallait décider le continent je
sais pas tu meurs mais cap la vente qui
s'est fait greffer des trucs et des
moustaches du chat tu crois je vais dire
afrique à ce dessein était géniale moi
je pense que c'est un lion que tu as
dessiner mais ça faisait pas trop lyon
quoi j'en ai vu c'est quoi ça on a
greffé une boîte de conserve un t-shirt
chemise
c'était très vert comme en suisse ans et
s'énerve on essaie de quoi brun
c'est un brin d'herbe la dernière fois
que j'ai 10 brins d'herbe c'était quand
j'avais pris la barre des 1 promet d'en
trouver de pousser faire le sifflement
bizarre là voilà et oui j'étais con non
mais là là là je les perds forfait met
instantanément le nom le mot été brûlés
et bunge et du niveau 1 sur ce jeu
attention un six-pièces star n'a pas -
cha ou une souris c'est un mammifère
non mais le mot était diablotins ok bon
c'est mort pour moi c'était une tête de
souris avec une règle de 30 cm une main
avec un peu de sang dessus ou de
moutarde une mayonnaise c'est du feu ah
bah voilà je vais faire un petit dessin
pour la fin croquettes
on va faire une gamelle déjà hop ça
c'est le sol va faire une flèche pour
montrer que c'est de ça qu'on parle et
ensuite on va faire un chat un chat
spectaculaire avec une oreille et un 9-2
licorne bon une licorne c'est pareil
qu'est ce que ces voix là qu'est ce donc
une étagère aller cette pièce aux
finitions de victoire ils ont été très
rares dans cette vidéo mais on finit sur
l'une d'elles donc c'est pas mal
merci à tous ceux qui ont pris plus ou
moins tendre envoyé un dessin c'est
super gentil il est vrai que certains
d'entre vous dessinez très très bien et
que certains d'entre vous des cimes
absolument pas bien je parle de pikachu
mais c'est pas tout je parle aussi de
pikachu il est vrai que vous êtes
définitivement plus fort que moi au
dessin voilà c'est la fin définitive de
ma carrière de dessinateur
y'a pas de problème merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo si vous aimez bien
les vidéos un peu spécial comme ça je
vous fait carrément intervenir n'hésitez
pas aimé la vidéo sa part grand plaisir
on se retrouve très vite dans une
nouvelle vidéo ça parle trop vite quand
même bizarre
[Musique]